you are watching ColdFusion TV
[Music]
hi and welcome to another ColdFusion
video earlier this month
Tesla overtook Ford and General Motors
in market capitalization this makes them
the most valuable car company in the
United States but first some eye poppin
news in the automotive world the market
value of Tesla the manufacturer of
high-end electric cars has actually
surpassed that of Ford and General
Motors amazingly Tesla has risen 42%
since the start of 2017 at about $300
per share the company is now valued at
fifty three billion dollars at the time
of creating this video just in case
you're wondering other car companies
such as Toyota are still valued higher
now many of you out there will be
scratching your heads and thinking how
is it possible for a company that lost
six hundred and seventy five million
dollars last year able to be worth more
than Ford and GM these companies made
nine point four and 4.6 billion dollars
last year respectively well maybe Tesla
somehow sold more cars not even close
Ford sold 17.5 million cars and GM 10
million cars in 2016 and Tesla just over
76,000
so what's going on here there must be
something more uh all of these investors
just really stupid no not really the
short end of the story is that investors
see a great deal of potential in Tesla
they're in love with the brand and the
idea of a person like Elon Musk from
solar energy to the gigafactory
to the Model S and Model X this
disruption written all over this company
and with that comes a great expectation
for the future the hard figures are
starting to come in as well and it's
looking positive in terms of growth
Tesla sales have gone up 300% in four
years while GM and Ford have hardly
budged investors see this as the start
of something and they're forecasting
much larger growth in the future
so where will this growth come from
mainly the Tesla Model 3 which is set
for a 2018 release when this car hits
the market it's set to unleash the
electric car into the hands of the
masses the base model of the model 3
will cost thirty five thousand dollars
before incentives now that doesn't sound
cheap but keep in mind that the standard
Tesla Model X goes for around seventy
five thousand dollars the model three is
proposed specs are as follows zero to
100 kilometers now in four seconds for
the premium model and six seconds for
the base model the range is 300 miles
from the premium model and 215 miles to
the base model the car has over 400,000
pre-orders in addition to this the Tesla
Giga factory is up and running supplying
new generation batteries to cars homes
companies parts of cities and even whole
islands like one of Hawaii's I've talked
about the Giga Factory in previous
videos it's the largest building on
earth in terms of physical footprint and
according to masks 100 factories could
power the entire planet
in terms of the future there's an
upcoming electric semi-trailer to be
made by Tesla and it's gonna be
announced in September so some people
out there are just waiting for something
to go catastrophically wrong though many
of those same people were waiting for
the same thing to happen to Amazon when
they weren't turning a profit for many
years in fact it was almost 10 years
after its founding until Amazon made his
full first year of profit
sometimes disruptive technology on a
global scale takes a lot of capital to
get the momentum needed to change the
world the fuel price could also be a
factor in Tesla's long term survival
I've heard some analysts say that OPEC
has failed and there's actually a
complete glut of oil around the world
and prices are only artificially high
for geopolitical reasons these analysts
say that the price could fall to almost
zero when all of this supply meets a
falling global demand
if petrol was super cheap like this
scenario it would put Tesla in a harder
place other analysts have suggested that
geopolitical tensions in the Middle East
coupled with an unwinding of the US
dollar as the world's reserve currency
could cause oil to spike and stay high
really it's too hard to say right now
which way this is gonna go so we'll just
leave this on the shelf
so he is one of the big questions is
Tesla overvalued the answer is yes but
technically almost everything on the
stock market is overvalued price to
earnings ratios are lofty but moreover
for the United States if we take the
measure of the Wilshire 5000 index which
is a broader measure than just the S&P
500 and divide it by the nation's GDP we
get a chart like this this chart is a
great way to see how fairly valued a
stock market is in comparison to a
nation's production a quick shout-out to
Mike Maloney for this little analyst
trick notice how after a steep rise in
the gradient there's always a market
sell-off and recession this is because
the market was overvalued and investors
began to realize right now we're in
risky territory and a mass market
sell-off will drag Tesla with it so
another question
our Tesla stocks a bubble technically
yes but again everything is in a bubble
right now stocks bonds real estate
student loans car loans and debt in
general and of course we have central
banks and their money printing to thank
for this situation but then again with
Tesla there's a bit of difference to
just blind hype investment the
difference is their track record when
Tesla started everyone laughed at them
people exclaimed that electric cars were
slow and have a short range who on earth
would want that it's just not going to
work they said time and time again Tesla
has come out and shocked people now
they're one of the most recognized new
brands of this century there's just not
another company out there like them at
the moment but this is a stock that has
defied everything that Wall Street has
thrown at it and it just doesn't fit any
conventional models it's clear that
Tesla has had an impact on the auto
industry remember before them there was
no mainstream electric car but now many
other established companies like
Mercedes BMW Porsche and even GM are
starting to build their own fully
electric cars
eventually they'll catch up but right
now Tesla has a head start and an
underdog story that people just seem to
love when you look at the things that
Tesla Energy is doing at the same time
it goes even wider than that it turns
into one company taking a brand new
approach to old sensory problems how
many times during your life do you get
to see things like this happen right in
front of your eyes so what do you guys
think do you reckon Tesla has a future
or do you think they're just going to
crash and burn let me know your thoughts
below thanks for watching this video
guys hope you got something out of it if
you just stumbled across this channel
feel free to subscribe this has been -
go go you've been watching cold fusion
and I'll catch you again soon for the
next video cheers guys have a good one
[Music]